If you're familiar with C#,
you may have seen extensions before.
Or if you've done any
work with Objective-C,
you may have seen its analog
to extensions, categories.
But for many of you,
extensions could be a brand new concept.
Kind of like adding an extension to
a house, extensions offer a way to
add computed properties and methods to
an existing class, struct, or enum.
They're often used to extend types for
which you don't have access to the code,
like Apple Frameworks, or
third party libraries.
I want to walk through an example that
I adapted from an example I found on
Andrew Bancroft's blog.
Which by the way you should definitely
check out if you haven't yet.
You can find a link to it
in the instructor's notes.